good morning good morning president
Levin Provos olive a secretary golf
crews chaplain Coogler masters deans and
honored guests and welcome women and men
of the class of 2016
welcome
welcome to Yale University and welcome
to Yale College I'm in in fact we're all
so excited to have you here we've been
thinking about you since april one when
Dean Brendel of Yale admissions told us
your names then we met some of you
during bulldog days we met a few more of
you this week in pre orientation
programs but at last class of 2016 you
are here welcome inside the walls onto
the playing fields into the classrooms
and the residential colleges welcome
welcome to the spaces and places you
soon will call home and welcome to all
the families and friends who brought you
to this day you've come from Gibraltar
and new haven from California and China
from Berkeley brookline in Brooklyn
thanks for having helped 1354 of the
world's most interesting and smartest
young women and men find their way to
today we are going to have exceptional
encounters with them over the next few
years in the classrooms and the dining
halls on the intramural courts in
extracurricular activities and let me
add that we'll have plenty of fun along
the way but 2016 back to you most of you
have just walked past the by Nicki
library and you will walk past it
several times a day over the next four
years there's a map inside it that comes
from the capital of New Spain in Mexico
City and you have in your lap a drawing
of the left hand side of the mapa as I
will call it today where disks count off
years taking the observer from the year
of the Spanish invasion to 1565
footprints orient the reader to time and
descent running top to bottom starting
with two seated lords who are depicted
as if they were pre-hispanic aztec
rulers but then we come to two figures
who faced one another
at left is the Viceroy the king's avatar
if you will the Viceroy who arrived in
New Spain in 1550 and he faces a stay
pending Guzman an Aztec noble who had
adopted a European surname and whom the
Viceroy appointed to serve as a local
governor during a crisis of rulership
when you go and take a look in the by
Nikki as I hope you will later today or
tomorrow you'll see that there are also
fields and orchards with the Glivec
names of the men and women who came to
own those fields and pictures of the
crops they raised all framed by bands of
water as a scholar of the ancient new
world I have been studying this mapa for
some years working with an international
team of colleagues to unlock unlock the
mapas story it turns out that the object
itself had a life and it's quite a story
when you look at it it will seem
seamless as if made at one time once and
for all and yet scientific examination
by specialists in the librarian museums
here reveals that it was cut and remade
at least three times and at least four
artists worked on it in those campaigns
expensive and rare pigments were
acquired from 800 miles away rather than
used the European ones what we see in
Guzman today his prominence in his role
in mid 16th century might have been
created only in retrospect in the
mullahs final version when his role in
shaping the course of history could be
established folded and put away the mapa
was then hidden from view for most of
its history and perhaps stored in a
monastery a book dealer brought it to
chicago in 1893 whence it passed through
a series of private hands in 1974 a Yale
freshman a yell freshman saw the listing
of a map in a sales cattle
log of a New York auction house and he
scraped together a few hundred dollars
from family and friends to make a bid he
won and then he kept it rolled up under
his bed in Timothy Dwight college for a
few months while he negotiated with the
by Nicki library to purchase it from him
for an amount that paid for the
remaining three years of tuition
on the mapa it's quite a story isn't it
do not try this at home on the mapa
gooseman looks beyond the Viceroy he
looks at the crown that floats over the
Viceroy his head do their two worlds
converge we know so little about the
difficulties and challenges to survive
in those years plagues ravaged
indigenous populations cutting them in
half time and again the rapacious
practices of the colonists to extract
wealth were an assault on the
environment it would take nimble
responses from indigenous peoples not to
be crushed nimble responses to swim and
a changing sea whose depth and
complexity they could not fathom and
ultimately to make a record like this
one the Viceroy and Guzman lived in two
different worlds in the middle of the
16th century perhaps communicating in
Latin in which they were both educated
Guzman knew nothing of Iberia or Rome
the Viceroy his brief was to keep order
and to make the colony productive for
Spain on the mapa both men speak those
are the little symbols in front of them
and they spoke for different
constituencies both lived simultaneously
in two different worlds yet in one
physical space do you will you we to
find ourselves in parallel universes
sometimes in what seemed to be different
worlds you the class of 2016 were born
most of you in 1994 in the world of 1994
we waited for the arrival of the mail
carrier and smooth white envelopes not
the pain of arriving email tweets and
texts a student's phone was in his or
her dorm room and nowhere else research
could be done only by showing up in some
place in the library or the lab or the
museum all the capacity
that world still exists and yet much of
it is for you like Latin to Guzman a
slightly foreign an archaic language and
until recently you've all been living
very intensely in your hometown among
your high school friends and over the
past few days you've been in constant
touch with them texting posting pictures
on facebook rolling over out of sleep to
look at your phone and to see that world
that may still seem more real than this
one in fact is your phone bugs buzzing
in your pocket or lap right now are your
fingers itching for your phones even in
this very second I bet they are how do
you leave the past 18 years behind and
find your new world for the viceroy to
succeed in New Spain he had to trust his
knowledge and his training from Madrid
and have mercy himself in his new world
trusting Guzman to be his guide what did
the two of them see as they look into
the future what do you see when you look
into your future our collective future
you arrived here with expectations some
of them your own some of them your
families others from your larger
community or from the group's you
believe you will affiliate with whether
a sports team or a theater group a
religious denomination or a political
organization and these expectations can
overtake your ability to explore the
opportunities here at Yale but you like
Guzman need to look beyond the obvious
you need to look into the unknown our
goal is for you to leave the
expectations of others behind you've
worked so hard to get here and you've
done so much of what others have asked
of you yet making independent choices
and charting your own future here at
Yale must be a first step toward
becoming an independent and autonomous
person you may think of the choices
you're going to be making
is largely about your courses or your
extracurricular or what we usually call
co-curricular life but these choices
also pertain to many other aspects of
your life by and large most of you have
filled almost every waking minute with
school lessons sport performance service
and other activities and although you
grumbled a bit about some of it you
measured up to all of it and it may be
easier to think that these choices now
are yours or so than the academic ones
but now you will need to own the
decisions behind saying yes and no you
won't be able to do everything that
calls to you decide carefully
consciously and ethically recognize the
impact and the responsibility you bear
if you make decisions to consume alcohol
and other drugs decide carefully and
recognize how poor decisions jeopardize
the integrity of friendships in our
community Guzman and the indigenous
communities he represented Commission
Native artists to paint the mapa to
argue for their autonomy their integrity
and their maturity their ability to
manage their own affairs their
recognition that they deserve fairness
in the assignment of land to grow maize
even Guzman's image when you take a look
at him tells us that he was the new
autonomous man of his century the
viceroy appears in perfect Spanish
attire but Guzman has adopted a ruffled
Spanish shirt to wear under a brilliant
red indigenous garment the new hybrid
dress of the native elite riding the
wave of the future he has already
changed and the artist captures it by
showing him moving into three dimensions
unlike the formal indigenous rulers who
proceed and succeed him all
conventionally depicted look now again
at Guzman staring off at the
crowd and hear these words from John
Keats he wrote these lines on a night in
1816 in response to his astonishment of
discovery in reading radiant
translations previously unknown to him
of Homer's Iliad and Odyssey then felt I
like some watcher of the skies when a
new planet swims into his kin or like
stout Cortez when with eagle eyes he
stared at the Pacific you two are about
to look into the unknown to swim or sail
from the known world into an uncharted
future as you do so you will discover
new worlds in history and science and
technology in works of art in the
written word and in the sea and sky the
by Nikhil the by Nicki library has
brought the remarkable mapa up to the
first floor this weekend and i invite
you to walk across the quadrangle today
or tomorrow to see it in person like
many treasures at Yale this map was here
for some years before it came to my
attention and I say with confidence that
you too can discover extraordinary and
surprising things hear things that no
one quite literally no one knows about
look beyond the obvious set your gaze on
what you cannot see yet and start
looking for new worlds